[Music]
it is the interview two months in the
making that is how long it has been
since Roseanne got fired and her show
got cancelled but she finally sat down
for her first TV conversation to talk
about it all and the one thing we know
about Roseanne when she opens her mouth
anything can and will happen listen I I
hate everyone equally Petey was with the
seemingly relaxed Roseanne at the end of
her all day maiya culpa mission in
Manhattan and during her onstage
conversation with her friend Rabbi
Shmuel II botella
Roseanne did not mince words when
talking about her former Roseanne
colleagues I'm sorry I think they lost a
good friend it is gonna be interesting
to see a bunch of really privileged
people who grew up in Hollywood writing
for the working class earlier in the day
she sat down with Fox News's Sean
Hannity Roseanne got candid about her
mental health you have said in the past
that you suffer from multiple
personality disorder well I don't suffer
from it anymore you don't I enjoy it
you've had crazy moments let's just be
honest we'll call it well your shouldn't
call a mental health patient crazy I
take an antidepressant and a
blood-pressure pill and then I take some
more antidepressants at one point
Roseanne spoke directly to the target of
her tweet Valerie Jarrett I'm so sorry
that you thought that my tweet was
racist because it wasn't but ultimately
she couldn't stop herself from getting
in one more personal jab plus I tell her
she's got to get a new haircut
I mean seriously she sneeze new haircut
[Music]
[Applause]